[Musique]
bienvenue dans le journal de campagne
sur France 24 à schrone verdian est avec
nous bonsoir acheren vous allez tout de
suite revenir bien sûr sur les résultats
définitifs du premier tour qui sont
tombés en début d'après-midi oui le
président sortant Emmanuel Macron arrive
donc en tête avec 27,84 % des voix suivi
de la candidate du Rassemblement
National Marine Le Pen qui récolte
23,15% des voix juste devant donc
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à
21,95% Éric Zemmour est à 7,07% Valérie
Pécresse à 4,78 Yannick Jadot a 4,63
Jean Lassalle à 3,13 Fabien Rousset la
2,28 Nicolas Dupont-Aignan a 2,06 Anne
Hidalgo a 1,75% Philippe Poutou à zéro
virgule 77% et enfin Natalie Arthaud
0,56% seulement des voix
Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen sont
déjà sur le terrain en campagne oui il
faut dire que le match retour du duel
Macron Le Pen après celui de 2017
s'annonce beaucoup plus serré alors
l'heure est au maintenus au discours
rassembleurs pour séduire tout d'abord
les abstentionnistes qui ont représenté
plus de 26% de l'électorat et pour
courtiser bien sûr les électeurs de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon arrivaient donc
troisièmes il a appelé à ne pas donner
une seule voix à Marine Le Pen mais n'a
pas appelé directement à voter Emmanuel
Macron contrairement à Anne Hidalgo
Yannick Jadot ou encore Fabien Roussel
le récap politique est signé Florent
rodo et Aurélien Porcher
c'est l'histoire d'un match retour bien
plus indécis
Emmanuel Macron le sait avec une réserve
de voie bien plus maigre qu'en 2017 il
n'a pas un seul jour à perdre au cours
convaincre
pour ce premier déplacement direction de
nain commune la plus pauvre de France
ici Marine Le Pen est arrivé en tête
avec 41% des voix c'est presque trois
fois plus que le président candidat
et j'ai pas envie ils vivent dans la
misère
les Français s'inquiète le CV bien sûr
vous savez pourquoi ils se rue vers le
Front national ou enfin
on n'a pas apporté des réponses faut pas
laisser passer un Front national
de ce du projet qu'on a tous ensemble
cette politique de la main tendue Marine
Le Pen l'a également faite sienne à son
QG ce matin la candidate du RN affiche
la mine des bonjour il ne faut jamais
perdre sa persévérance
quand on sait qu'on a raison il faut
continuer à se battre envers et contre
tout quelques autographes signées en
sortant avant de prendre la route de
l'Yonne avec le même objet actif
rassembler le plus large possible autour
de sa candidature si on arrive au
pouvoir c'est pas le rassemblement
national qui va arriver au pouvoir mais
c'est un gouvernement d'union nationale
avec des gens de la droite de la gauche
qui sont attachés à l'idée de nation et
qui sont attachés pas seulement à nos
modes de vie mais à d'autres modèles de
protection sociale et qui veulent éviter
de déposséder la France de leur
souveraineté ce que fera Emmanuel Macron
50 plus
pour lui ce lundi matin est synonyme de
gueule de bois
sentiment mi-figue mi-raisin pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon entre fierté d'avoir
réalisé son meilleur score à la
présidentielle et déception de voir le
second tour lui échapper une nouvelle
fois il donne sa consigne et il ne faut
pas
être en capacité de nuire à Emmanuel
Macron c'est l'autre but des insoumis
s'agira aux élections législatives de
faire le nécessaire parce qu'Emmanuel
Macron je le crois peut ne pas avoir de
majorité à l'Assemblée il peut s'agir de
lui imposer une cohabitation
les législatives il les a aussi en ligne
de mire 4e très loin du podium Éric
Zemmour rappelle à voter Marine Le Pen
et prépare déjà l'après je suis
déterminé à poursuivre le combat avec
tous ceux qui sont à mes côtés tous ceux
qui nous rejoindront dans les semaines à
venir et je vous dirai très vite la
forme que prendra notre action notre
projet même dans ces pires cauchemars
elle ne pensait pas être en dessous et
pourtant claque humiliante pour Valérie
Pécresse et les républicains sous la
barre fatidique des 5% pas de
remboursement des frais de campagne le
Bureau politique DLR a été pour le moins
agité la candidate est au bord des
larmes je suis endetté personnellement à
hauteur de 5 millions d'euros c'est pour
cela que je lance ce matin un appel
national au don il en va de la survie
des républicains et au-delà de la survie
de la droite républicaine à gauche
Yannick Jadot lui aussi fait un appel au
don
comme Fabien Roussel et Anne Hidalgo
tout trois ratent la marche des 5%
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
c'est sûr que c'est deux semaines de
campagne vont être cruciales oui Carla
mécanique du report des voies est plus
imprévisible que jamais alors dans le
camp du président candidat on le Martel
encore et encore rien n'est gagné tout
reste possible on en parle avec notre
éditorialiste politique roselynefeuvre
bonjour Roselyne trois mots tout d'abord
pour
quatre mots alors pour pour décrire ce
premier tour oui j'ai choisi quatre mots
remake engloutissement une défaite
triomphale et une défaite ironique alors
le remake bien évidemment vous allez
deviné c'est le match retour Emmanuel
Macron Marine Le Pen comme s'il n'avait
comme si rien n'avait changé depuis 2017
mais en fait tout a changé lui a été
président pendant 5 ans il a connu des
crises le terrorisme le covid et
l'Ukraine et son score a progressé
d'ailleurs depuis 2017 donc alors il a
beaucoup gouverné à droite maintenant il
va falloir qu'il donne un vrai coup de
barre à gauche Marine Le Pen elle c'est
normalisée grâce à qui grâce à Éric
qui a endossé le rôle du diable elle
s'est préparée elle a un nouveau duel
qui en 2017 avait été tellement raté
qu'elle en avait fait une dépression
après alors est-ce qu'elle est prête
aujourd'hui c'est la question à 1000
points l'engloutissement et bien
l'englouti le sait l'engloutissement de
des deux parties qui ont dans le fond
était dominants pendant plus de 70 ans
dans la vie politique française bien
évidemment qui a rythmé la Cinquième
République le PS et
les républicains deux parties dont Yann
Hidalgo qui fait moins que Jean Lassalle
avec 1,7% un échec qui va peser lourd
très lourd dans l'histoire du PS que
va-t-il rester et bien j'ai trouvé la
meilleure formule dans l'un des papiers
de nos confrères du monde qui écrivent
des seconds couteaux qui s'agite autour
d'un maigre feu de joie et quelques
éléphants socialistes qui dansent dans
l'ombre pour essayer de garder une place
je trouve que c'est un beau résumé
l'autre vous l'avez compris deux Valérie
Pécresse alors elle aussi qui tient la
Séville on vient de l'entendre c'est
presque pathétique elle elle dit qu'elle
est endettée elle a fait 4,7% donc
que va-t-il advenir des républicains et
de cette recomposition ou décomposition
c'est pas trop en tout cas il ne veut
pas être drôle de se réveiller dans la
peau ce matin de Valérie Pécresse et
puis la victoire victorieux c'est celle
de Mélenchon vous l'avez compris parce
que il a presque franchi les portes du
Paradis avec 22% c'est lui aujourd'hui
la force de gauche c'est lui qui sera
peut-être faiseur de roi alors est-ce
que elles sont électorat apparemment un
tiers un tiers ira avec chez Macron
l'autre chez Le Pen les autres l'eau
tiède va s'abstenir et puis la défaite
ironique et bien c'est celle d'Eric
Zemmour pourquoi pas parce que lui et
ben il croyait faire battre Marine Le
Pen et en fait il lui a fait la courte
échelle il a il en a fait une sorte de
française qui aiment les chats
c'est peut-être trop long pour une autre
question si on va faire le match voilà
en 2017 de projet diamétralement opposés
oui bah oui c'est la vision de deux
France j'apporte rien de nouveau mais
schémati si on schématise un peu la une
France ouverte une France fermée celle
d'une France en colère mais c'était déjà
le cas en 2017 sauf que là ça se quand
même le si on additionne le total des
populistes de gauche d'extrême gauche
Éric Zemmour Marine Le Pen on est quand
même à 50 entre 53 et 55 % et bien et
l'autre côté une France qui va mieux oui
celle de la mondialisation donc la
France fermait la France ouverte donc ce
qui va se passer d'abord c'est toute
cette semaine ça va être projet contre
projet d'ailleurs tous les soirs à
chaîne et Stéphanie vous allez on va
avoir droit alors Emmanuel Macron était
à tel endroit Marine Le Pen était à tel
endroit et chacun va critiquer le projet
de l'autre comme d'habitude et cette
fois les deux projets vont être scrutés
sans oublier peut-être que un Emmanuel
Macron qui lui n'a pas fait campagne et
qui va peut-être
faire comme parfois les Déus ex machina
sortent de la boîte en faisant quelques
coups d'éclat on verra lesquels merci
beaucoup Roselyne et on vous retrouve
demain dans mardi politique et à laisser
une campagne qui s'est voulu modérer de
proximité centrée sur le pouvoir d'achat
Marine Le Pen c'est donc qualifié au
second tour oui elle a visiblement
appris de ses erreurs et la présence
d'Éric Zemmour on en parlait à l'instant
beaucoup plus radical dans ses
propositions à largement contribué à
lisser son image après un point à son QG
de campagne aujourd'hui Marine Le Pen
est reparti sur le terrain dans l'Yonne
notamment à Soucy où l'on rejoint notre
envoyé spécial Clovis cazali bonjour
Clovis Marine Le Pen veut donc
transformer ce second tour en référendum
anti Macron
absolument et c'était un déplacement
surprise car ce n'était pas prévu sur
l'agenda de Marine Le Pen mais voilà
Emmanuel Macron le président sortant
était dans les hauts de France alors
elle l'a montré en venant ici dans
l'Yonne à la rencontre d'un agriculteur
céréalier qui a été prévenu à 12h30
qu'elle viendrait un peu plus tard dans
l'après-midi et elle a donc discuté avec
lui devant les caméras elle a parlé
énormément pouvoir d'achat elle a
déclaré notamment qu'elle voulait rendre
aux Français leur bonheur et elle a dit
que c'était plus possible ces
augmentations de gaz d'essence et
qu'avec elle tout changerait comment
elle va faire et bien en arrêtant de
suivre les règles européennes et
pourtant elle l'a répété elle refuse de
quitter l'Europe elle veut juste arrêter
de suivre les règles européennes quitte
à ce froisser avec les autres les autres
pays appartenaient et une nouvelle fois
elle a appelé les Français de droite de
gauche à la retrouver à se rassembler
derrière sa candidature pour contrer
Emmanuel Macron pour elle tous ceux qui
n'ont pas voté pour Emmanuel Macron
doivent la choisir elle on saura ça dans
les prochains jours et à travers ce
déplacement Clovis Marine Le Pen qu'on
voit clairement les voix du monde rural
absolument et ce n'est pas la première
fois à Marine Le Pen qui ne cesse de
répéter que c'est la candidate de la
France des oubliés ce abandonnés par les
gouvernants les gouvernements précédents
pendant des décennies elle vise le monde
rural ici par exemple dans l'Yonne elle
a quand même terminé en tête au premier
tour 31% des voix et 40% des voix ici
sont allés à l'extrême droite c'est bien
qu'elle a un réservoir Marine Le Pen qui
souhaite
démétropolisé le la France en gros
repeuplé les campagnes elle dit qu'il
faut arrêter avec la désertification
qu'avec elle tout changera et que des
réformes structurelles peuvent être
menées tout de suite si on s'éloigne de
l'Europe elle veut se montrer comme la
candidate du peuple vous l'aurez compris
contre le monde des élites incarné selon
elle par Emmanuel Macron merci beaucoup
Clovis pour toutes ces précisions depuis
l'Yonne et puis un déplacement aussi
bien sûr pour Emmanuel Macron à Shrek
Emmanuel Macron qui désormais bien
obligé de faire campagne oui il s'est
rendu aujourd'hui à Denain dans le Nord
sur des terres électorama électoralement
pardon favorable à Marine Le Pen il est
ensuite allé à Carvin il se rend
maintenant à Lens avant de rentrer à
Paris on retrouve devant son QG de
campagne dans le 8e arrondissement de la
capitale marie-chauster bonjour Marie
cette fois-ci Emmanuel Macron ne peut
pas faire l'impasse donc sur sa campagne
ah oui pour Emmanuel Macron il n'est
plus question de déléguer dans cette
période de l'antre de Tours le président
sortant veut faire lui-même campagne il
a annoncé d'ailleurs cette semaine pas
moins de trois déplacements et dans les
régions et pas n'importe quelle région
puisqu'il était aujourd'hui dans les
Hauts-de-France il sera demain dans le
Grand Est en fin de semaine il sera en
région provençale peu Côte d'Azur donc
au lendemain du premier tour Emmanuel
Macron veut faire campagne sur les
terres même de Marine Le Pen il l'a dit
aujourd'hui à Dena à la mi-journée il
cherche à convaincre et à ramener
l'électorat de Marine Le Pen vers lui en
se positionnant comme le seul candidat
crédible du pouvoir d'achat bien sûr à
l'issue de ce premier tour Emmanuel
Macron peut compter sur le soutien d'un
certain nombre de candidats malheureux à
l'issue de ce premier tour mais il le
sait ce ne sera pas suffisant la vraie
réserve de voie est à trouver chez les
mélenchonistes et c'est d'ailleurs tout
le sens de son déplacement en fin de
semaine à Marseille puisque c'est à
Marseille que Jean-Luc Mélenchon était
arrivé en tête du premier tour mais pour
convaincre ces électeurs là et bien il
faudra se positionner en candidat
républicain en candidat du rassemblement
et c'est ici au QG ce qu'on essaie de
faire de créer l'image du candidat du
rassemblement en tout cas parmi les
figures politiques proches d'Emmanuel
Macron que nous avons pu rencontrer des
ce matin au QG de campagne d'Emmanuel
Macron et bien le credo reste le même
qu'avant le premier tour rien n'est joué
il reste bien évidemment mobilisé merci
beaucoup Marie et vous allez continuer à
nous faire vivre cette campagne dans les
deux semaines à venir on va maintenant
s'intéresser à la sociologie de
l'électorat avec Karina chabour qui nous
a rejoint bonjour Carina bonjour Rachman
alors vous avez épluché une enquête
ipso sopra Steria notre partenaire
réalisé entre le 6 et le 9 avril quels
en sont les principaux enseignements et
bien première enseignement chez les
jeunes c'est clairement Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui attire le plus
puisque 31% des 18 24 ans disent voter
pour lui 34% chez les 24 34 ans devant
Marine Le Pen Emmanuel Macron ou encore
Yannick Jadot alors qu'on le sait à
l'écologie est un thème plébiscité par
cette catégorie celle-ci pour cent des
18 24 ans 10 voté pour le candidat vert
4 % des 24 34 ans à l'inverse chez les
personnes âgées c'était manuel Macron
qui raffent la mise 41% des électeurs de
70 ans et plus lui accorde son soutien
30% des 60 69 ans loin devant Marine Le
Pen Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou encore la
candidate malheureuse de droite Valérie
Pécresse et puis quid du vote selon la
profession et la géographie karena et
bien Marine Le Pen est en tête chez les
ouvriers chez les employés avec à chaque
fois 36% là où Emmanuel Macron mène la
course chez les cadres les professions
intermédiaires et vous voyez Jean-Luc
Mélenchon arrive en deuxième position
sur ces deux catégories quant au plus
quant au plus diplômé sans surprise il
vote en priorité pour Emmanuel Macron
puis Jean-Luc Mélenchon Marine Le Pen
est-elle hésité par les non diplômés
enfin la candidate du rassemblement
national attire le plus dans les
villages et petites villes là où
Emmanuel Macron c'est lui davantage dans
les métropoles Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
bien lui attire aussi bien la France des
petits que des grandes villes et la
grande gagnante de cette de ce premier
tour c'est aussi l'abstention quel est
le profil des abstentionnistes et bien
ce sont aussi bien des hommes que des
femmes quasi à égalité surtout des
jeunes des ouvriers on les trouve aussi
plus représentés si l'on se réfère au
premier tour du vote de 2017 et bien
chez les personnes qui avaient voté pour
François Fillon ou encore Marine Le Pen
merci beaucoup Karina pour votre
éclairage on va prendre un peu de
distance avec notre module vu de
l'étranger oui comment les résultats du
premier tour de la présidentielle en
France sont-ils perçus analysés depuis
Berlin Tunis Abidjan ou encore
Washington tour d'horizon tout de suite
des réactions grâce à nos correspondants
anne-maillet lilia Blaise Hanane Ferjani
et Mathieu mapin
[Musique]
ici à Berlin on s'attendait à une
répétition du duel de 2017 entre
Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen mais
l'issue du second tour qui s'annonçait
est une source d'inquiétude la grande
majorité des responsables politiques
allemands veulent croire en la victoire
du président sortant mais la presse elle
met en garde contre un tremblement de
terre politique si Marine Le Pen arrive
au pouvoir avec des conséquences
dramatiques pour la France mais aussi
l'Europe et donc l'Allemagne le
quotidien d'Yvette appelle même le
gouvernement à mettre en place une
cellule de crise pour se préparer aux
conséquences d'une éventuelle victoire
de la candidate d'extrême droite
ici à Tunis une partie de l'élite
tunisienne et aussi des commentateurs
sur les réseaux sociaux ont largement
suivi ce premier scrutin du fait des
liens historiques et économiques entre
les deux pays mais aussi préoccupé par
la montée des extrêmes en France qui
pourraient en remettre en question les
accords bilatéraux entre les deux pays
et également la politique d'octroi des
visas certains condensateurs ont aussi
comparé la défaite de la gauche
française aux problèmes de la gauche
tunisienne qui a du mal depuis ces 10
dernières années à s'unir en une
mouvance d'opposition un expert en
sondage que j'ai pu contacter a
également souligné la portée universelle
du scrutin français qui montre
finalement que beaucoup d'électeurs
votent plutôt pour des valeurs et des
personnes que pour des programmes une
idée similaire à celle de l'élection
présidentielle de 2019 en Tunisie qui
avait largement porté au pouvoir
ici à Abidjan peu de réaction au
lendemain de l'annonce des résultats de
ce premier tour de la présidentielle
française on a pu parler avec des
Ivoiriens qui nous ont dit ne pas être
étonnés par ce duel Emmanuel Macron
Marine Le Pen au second tour la presse
ivoirienne parle peu de ce scrutin
aujourd'hui pas de réaction non plus du
côté des politiques mais ceux qui
suscitent le plus de commentaires
notamment sur Internet ce sont les
résultats du vote de français de Côte
d'Ivoire 39,5% des voix pour Macron
suivi de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a fait
une belle progression depuis 2017 avec
29% des voix Marine Le Pen a beaucoup
moins convaincu l'électorat et obtenu
moins de 7% en revanche et rexembourg
est arrivé à la troisième place avec 11%
des voix et c'est justement cette
popularité du candidat d'extrême droite
qui choque certains Ivoiriens et Franco
Ivoiriens
ici à Washington Joe Biden et son
administration garde un œil attentif sur
ce qui est qualifié je cite d'émergence
d'une forme de trumpisme français la
présence de Marine Le Pen au second tour
n'a pas échappé aux éditorialistes du
Washington Post ou du New-York Times qui
rapporte effectivement l'inquiétude
toute relative cependant des conseillers
de Joe Biden ou encore des
fonctionnaires du département d'État
rassemblés autour d'Anthony blinken la
France est effectivement un partenaire
diplomatique de premier plan pour les
États-Unis et tout particulièrement
depuis l'émergence de la guerre en
Ukraine même s'il n'est pas considéré
ici que la victoire de Marine Le Pen
face au président de la République
Emmanuel Macron soit le scénario le plus
probable il n'est néanmoins pas écarté
et les diplomates américains se
préparent à toutes les éventualités
[Musique]
et voilà c'est tout pour ce soir à
suivre sur notre antenne votre débat
Stéphanie à 19h10 histoire de Paris
consacré donc aux résultats de ce
premier tour de la présidentielle et
puis à 20h05 précisément heure de Paris
ce sera planète Élisée 2022 présenté par
Raphaël Kahn et Jean-François acquis de
France Info soirée de décryptage des
résultats en France et à l'international
quant à moi je vous dis à demain sur
l'horaire habituel 20h15 heure de Paris
merci ashraine c'est donc la fin de
France 2022 heure du choix on vous
retrouve demain bien sûr ça sera à 20h15
comme tous les soirs c'est avec vous
qu'on referme cette tranche
d'informations mais on se retrouve dans
un peu plus de 5 minutes alors restez
avec